you hungry it's going food oh man they
in the life huh
is that what we're calling this in life
today is gonna be not glamorous I'm
gonna feed the dog are you hungry
I'm wearing the same shirt they had on
yesterday I slept in it
mady's morning meals usually take a
little more prep time because in the
morning he doesn't usually like to eat
just dry food he likes to have a little
mixture so that's what we're doing this
smells like garbage we already went for
a morning walk
now I'm deciding if I'm going to shower
before I attempt to shooting a video or
if I just throw some makeup on and brush
my hair again and make it look like I'm
clean sometimes I like to sit right here
well Maddy's eating his breakfast I need
to think about my breakfast it's still
pretty early
how'd you trick me into feeding you so
early usually it's around 10:00 it's not
then it's way earlier I got a few Amazon
fresh deliveries very important cleaning
supplies the one thing that I had
ordered is not here I ordered disposable
coffee cups but I've got toilet paper
where's my coffee cups
course I'll put these items away where's
my Glock because I wonder where they are
I'm gonna be spending a week in New York
and then my sister's wedding week and
then I'm flying back to LA so I've got a
lot of videos to prep so that you guys
will have some entertainment while I am
unable to make content
that's really hot
I usually like to do my email here in
the kitchen Matthew
now that you just went out literally
five minutes ago
five minutes bud he's like a small child
I forgot that I was still recording look
who's back back again Maddie's back tell
your friends
time to clean up a little guess I'll
take a shower
ah sit-up found the dog
we've got a video exporting step one of
the iphone 7 rumors video that I just
previously posted usually when I film
these I do a screen recording and I use
a webcam and a microphone and I sit and
talk and I look for new information I do
a quick rough edit in ScreenFlow and
then I take it into Final Cut and then I
add some finishing touches that some
music fix audio and then export it and I
upload it so that's what I've been doing
well this little boy has been a rally
Hyo though I couldn't bring myself to a
make up on though that's probably the
hardest part for me is why sometimes I
don't actually make videos because I
hate wearing makeup I hate putting it on
I hate the whole process it makes me
feel so just stuck inside my skin I
don't really know how to explain it
unless you've actually worn makeup and
you have a similar feeling some people
say just saying you don't need make-up
you might not need it but it definitely
will make your skin look better and you
definitely do feel better after I'm like
looking at myself on screen and I'm like
you need to cover some of that up but
when it really comes down to it I don't
actually care I used to care so much
when I was younger I wouldn't even leave
the house without putting makeup on or
like doing my hair just making sure that
I looked perfect here's the thing nobody
else actually really cares except
yourself but yet you're trying to put on
this face in this this whole facade of
for other people but nobody else
actually cares I don't care if my
friends wear makeup I don't care if I'm
out to lunch or dinner and somebody is
not wearing makeup I really was a time
in the place for all of those things and
I think when you do get older you sort
of figure out what actually matters and
what
matter I think I'm still trying to
figure those things out so is Patti a
bunch of you guys were tweeting me and
st. Justine has been confirmed there is
not going to be a headphone jack in the
iPhone 7 so let's see what we can find